معنا من اسطنبول الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي العقيد الركن حاتم كريم
الفلاحي عقيد حاتم مرحبا بك معنا كيف ترصد
محاولات التقدم لجيش الاحتلال في المناطق
الوسطى والجنوبيه من
القطاع نعم تحيه لكم ومشاهدي قناه الجزيره
اهلا بك نعم لا شك بانه الاحتلال بعد ان
يعني تقريبا انهى عملياته العسكريه
الكبيره ك ما يقول في القطاع الشمالي توجه
بعد الهدنه باتجاه القاطع الجنوبي ثم بعد
ذلك وسع من عملياته او طور من عملياته
العسكريه باتجاه القاطع الاوسط وبذلك
اصبحت المحاور الرئيسيه الان للجيش
الصهيوني في في في قطاع غزه باتجاهين
الاتجاه الاول هو اتجاه خان يونس مدينه
خان يونس والاتجاه الثاني هو باتجاه
البريج ودير البلاح وهذه المناطق يعني
فحقي الان يحاول هو الان يتجمع على طريق
صلاح الدين الذي استطاع ان ينفذ اليه من
خاصره منطقه غلاف غزه باتجاه البحر ويحاول
ان يتقدم من هذا باتجاه باتجاه الجنوب
بثلاثه محاور المحور الاول هو المحور الذي
ينطلق باتجاه شارع جمال عبد الناصر وصولا
الى سجن اصداء المركزي الذي تم تسليم احدى
وجبات اطلاق الصراح بالنسبه للاسرى في
الفتره الماضيه في تلك المنطقه يحاول ان
يتقدم باتجاه بهذا الاتجاه بمحور رئيسي
ويحاول ان يتقدم ايضا بمحور باتجاه طريق
المحطه او طريق السكه وهناك محور اخر ايضا
هو محور صلاح الدين الرئيسي الذي يصل الى
دوار بني سهيله لذلك هو يحاول ان يتقدم
بثلاثه محاور من هذه المنطقه يضاف الى ذلك
بان هناك محور اللي هو المحور الشرقي الذي
ينطلق من منطقه غلاف غزه باتجاه خربه
خزاعه باتجاه عبسان باتجاه دوار منطقه بني
سهيله هذا ايضا يعتبر محور رئيسي بالنسبه
ل القطعات التي تقاتل في هذه المنطقه هناك
الفرقه 98 وهناك الفرقه 162 هي التي تقاتل
في هذين المحورين والقطعات وصلت الى اعداد
كبيره جدا الاعداد وصلت الى اكثر من سبعه
الويه في هذه المنطقه اما في القاطع
الاوسط فالفرق 36 هي التي تقاتل في منطقه
القاطع الاوسط طوال الفتره الماضيه
استطاعوا ان يخرقوا في مناطق معينه ولكنهم
لم يستطيعوا ان يتقدموا الى الامام هو
يحاول الان ان يتقدم الى الى الامام
ويحاول ان يحكم الطوق بصوره كامله على
منطقه خان يونس على اعتبار ان هذه المنطقه
هي منطقه الثقل الرئيسي بالنسبه لفصائل
المقاومه ويعتبر بانه فيها مؤسسات وبنى
تحتيه بما فيها مخازن عتاد ومراكز القياده
والسيطره بالنسبه لقيادات المقاومه وبذلك
هو يحاول ان يسوق مثل هذه الامور للوصول
الى هذه المنطقه ولكن طوال هذه الفتره
جبها بمقاومه شديده جدا باداء متطور
ومتصاعد من قبل المقاومه في القاطعين
القاطع الاوسط والقاطع الجنوبي لذلك نرى
بان العمليات العسكريه متعثره بشكل كبير
جدا في هذه المنطقتين يحاول ان يضغط خلال
هذه الفتره على اعتبار ان الوقت قصير جدا
واحتمال ان يدخل في المرحله الثالثه التي
هي ستكون اقل كثافه ولكن يبدو بان هذه
المنطقه باعتبارها منطقه استراتيجيه ومهمه
بالنسبه للطرفين يمكن ان تتاخر مساله
الانتقال في هذه المرحله على عكس القطع
الشمالي الذي بدا ينسحب الان بصوره تق شبه
كليه خصوصا وانه في المرحله الاولى بعد
انتهاء الهدنه قال بانه سحب 70% من
القطعات التي كانت تقاتل في الشمال وهذا
يعطينا يعني تقريبا توضيح بان هذه القطعات
سحبت من الشمال وتم تحويلها باتجاه الجنوب
طيب عقيد
حاتم هناك اشتباكات بين المقاومه وقوات
الاحتلال في محيط مركز مدينه خان يونس ما
طبيعه المعركه في تلك المنطقه خاصه مع مع
عمليات تركيز القصف من قبل قوات الاحتلال
لهذه المنطقه مدينه خان
يونس نعم القتال يحتدم في هذه المنطقه
لان الجيش الصهيوني يحاول ان يتقدم وعندما
يتقدم يستخدم ما لديه من امكانيات وقدرات
قتاليه بما فيها استخدام نفعيه بكثافه
كبيره جدا استخدام الطائرات والقصف
المدفعي والطائرات المسيره وكل ما يمتلك
من من قطعات ومن ادوات تدميريه لكي يستطيع
ان يتقدم في هذه المناطق وبالمقابل هناك
ايضا دفاعات موجوده في هذه المنطقه هذه
الدفاعات هي صحيح متحركه وليست ثابته
ثابته في مناطق محدده وليس في مناطق تماس
ثابته في هذه المنطقه ولكنها تحاول وقف
تقدم القطعات في هذه المنطقه من من خلال
ترك مفارز تعويق من خلال استخدام الاسلحه
المتيسر عليها من هاونات ومن اسلحه
وصواريخ وما الى ذلك من من عمليات قصف
وبذلك هي تحاول ايقاف القطعات في هذه
المنطقه بما فيها الكمان الثابته والكمان
المتحركه وبما فيها ايضا استخدام الاسلحه
المتيسر من من من القذائف المضاده للدروع
اضافه الى المضاده الى الاشخاص فلذلك نرى
بان المعركه تحتدم في هذه المنطقه لانه
هناك اشتباك قريب ما بين القطعات وهناك
يعني قطعات تحاور التقدم وقطعات تتصدى
لهذا التقدم شكرا جزيلا لك من اسطنبول
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي العقيد الركن
حاتم كريم الفلاحي